I think I don't I think they're uh
jeopardizing their chances to be wise
but I think there's a lot of potential
husbands but you could also make the
argument there's shortage of both
because they're being turned off because
that makes sense because of the law yeah
yeah and so
yeah but I think the more women are
jeopardizing their uh potential to be
wives but but I think there's loads of
potential husbands who can actually get
into the husband role like they could be
but it's just they don't have the right
girl to become that exactly what what
mistakes do you see girls make that
takes them out of the running to be
wives
um I don't know I just wanna
if I could just
simply say it well if they're if they
could easily get sucked into things like
feminism like you know overall yeah I
know people say but there's this type of
feminism
you know I think we could all agree that
all this like men are trash and all that
stuff that's probably the biggest
mistake if you can if you can allow that
in
you know in your mindset and think that
that's okay that's probably the biggest
one
that turns men off because you can even
just say that's that that's enough
because in feminism they say you don't
have to do this he could just accept you
the way you are you don't have to do
anything you just have to exist and
going back to the actual topic of what
we were talking about the bar is set
very just ridiculously high for men to
the point where I I I think that they
deliberately do that to take the piss
it's just so high it's unattainable but
for women I feel like there is no but it
doesn't even exist so you can see that
there you see the girls on my 300 pound
life with a man
is that monthly no I haven't even seen
that
yeah I personally I personally think
that the problem these days in modern
culture whatever you want to call it is
that people is actually focusing on the
wrong things so these girls are talking
about and I think there was recently
these guys who came in and said they
were high value men and they wear flashy
stuff they act you know a certain way
and I can tell you that a high value
woman the ones that you actually the
good ones that you want as a wife
they're not going to say yes to that guy
because they're gonna see him and be
like oh he's so insecure he needs to
drive a Lambo in order to feel slightly
slightly better about himself slightly
because guess what under all those
cologne nice shirts whatever Gucci belts
whatever you want to call it
it's a very insecure person who needs
that physical
reassurance because guess what the the
real men the real value men they don't
wear anything flashy you don't even know
they have money that's the beauty they
wear same t-shirt every day and they're
the true men with the values they're the
ones who they're dangerous they they
know their stuff and if they want to
inflict danger they know but the beauty
about them is that they have that that
that everything's under control so if
anyone wants to mess with them you know
you're gonna get burned but because
they're so in control and in their King
energy they they they the girls know
that he is a good person to be with
because he can protect me but he also
will respect me and love me so I think
yeah sorry bro
um so quick question um this is just
from the chat
um have you had a BDSM relationship
personally mean no but it's something
that you saw 50 Shades of Gray and
you're like sign me up no no
uh can I just put it out there the 50
Shades of Gray is the worst depiction of
BDSM there is okay ever it is it is a
completely wrong and that is an abusive
relationship that is not BDSM that is
not from every relationship Every Woman
friends what's the guy's name because I
know there was a reading the book on the
show oh Mr Gray yeah well it's the same
thing girls like the handmaid's tale
this is the thing like so girls are
attracted to their that's the thing
they're confused what they want is the
healthy relationship the king who is you
can tell he can inflict you know trauma
and real real real real things like he
can protect his family he can protect
his people but he controls it he's in
control of himself these girls are
fooled because they don't we sometimes
when you're young and you don't know
better you're followed by these girls
you know girls intuition but we're not
fooled they don't use that language
because it's not correct women women's
intuition is so freaking I'm not saying
we're not we no no we are not like that
when we say words like fooled it's
implying that we don't know what we're
doing and that it's a cop-out for women
it's like oh we're fooled by the flashy
stuff come on okay I'm not trying to say
that I'm not trying to say that
everyone's like that but from personal
experience I I was I I was I am a person
who fell for someone who I thought was a
king he tried he didn't see a single red
flag because I would I didn't know how
to see it you didn't okay this is a
thing I'm just being like I'm just being
real with you it just sounds like
excuses no no no I I of course I believe
you yeah and actually for the longest
time I noticed that I attracted the same
type of guys men that unfortunately
didn't think about me it was all about
them it wasn't about me and and you know
what I realized that what was the
constant here me yeah that's the one
thing that hasn't changed so why am I
getting the same experiences so rather
than try to say that it's their fault
I looked at myself and I said what am I
not what am I missing right how am I
going to take you to get there though
like what age did you start looking at
yourself because that's what I encourage
all my female friends to just look at
himself and see the problems within them
so before they start putting a finger
yeah look you should start start
whenever I mean the thing is is that
like I was always a bit late in dating
scene anyways like my first and only
boyfriend was when I was 22. I was with
him for two years I honestly thought
this was someone I was going to marry
that's how serious I was but guess what
he was a narcissist he gaslighted me all
the time his whole family was was he was
he diagnosed
um he's very self-centered and
everything was about but he was never
diagnosed because okay because like
again this in a way is an excuse like
with that women use because if he hasn't
seen a therapist and he hasn't been
professionally diagnosed you can't
diagnose him as a narcissist I think
it's difficult because I know it's not
it's not difficult you know it's like if
he if he's not hasn't been diagnosed as
a narcissist we can't just go around
calling people narcissists so I'm gonna
say narcissistic traits what that means
is that a person is coming across a
certain way but they're not diagnosed I
apologize if anyone pay offense to that
I think I want to answer Paul's question
um with regards to what are the mistakes
women make
um in becoming web so I think personally
today's women think that identifying
with feminism is a good long-term
strategy
and it's clearly not because
as you said men appreciate youth men
appreciate fertility so I think the
biggest problem with feminism for me is
that
feminism encourages Independence right
and in today's society for females
Independence means in my opinion
incredibly promiscuous so they end up
sleeping Memorial Pool Guys figuring to
do the same thing as men because
normally independence mean you can do
what you want right by yourself
but it's clearly not working out for
anyone I mean suppose all the statistics
about
I mean what age are women getting
married now what age are women having
kids now like it's not working out for
women at all so go ahead can I mention
that that video I mean
the is that a big deal like what they
were mentioning you're exaggerating like
the light thing like come on
what if it was like let me just try to
guess like